often but i i'm different so that ladies  i don't watch corn and i don't no way  yeah good for you  you don't really  help  that's what you're saying you say you  don't do self-help yeah good for you man  because i understand and you will  understand the deplete feeling after the  tiredness all of those things i think is  it speaks more volumes for your  self-control if you can  hold that in yeah because i think that's  the hardest thing in life to control  other than eating  the physical craving for the opposite  sex is the hardest thing to to control  in any form and i think corn plays a  massive factor in not having to have any  self-control yeah  what benefits have you what benefits  have you seen from cutting that out